Oh your first blink talking about the
event that we're here to a comedy by
Blake what's the event that we're here
for tonight so then I started three
years ago partnered with Red Bull and
all proceeds benefit the team Griffin
foundation which my brother and I
started four years ago and you know our
main focus is to help at-risk youth in
Oklahoma where we're from California and
Detroit and I'm hoping hoping to move
that onto two more places so really just
giving kids a chance or the tools to do
whatever they want which is why I'm here
today because somebody did that for me
and no strings attached and I want to do
the same yeah no okay this comedy thing
where did you decide like you really
wanted to go fully on comedy uh that's a
good question hi I just always love
comedy like as a kid and like when I
moved to LA when I got drafted there I
met some some friends who were stand-up
comedians and kind of followed them
around and watched what they did and
then you know some of them encouraged me
to start writing my own stuff and I did
and then finally I got up the nerve to
do it and then kind of the rest is
history
this thing that people say it's one was
terrifying things to do yeah this is
going up on stage yeah absolutely
how would you compare it to going out on
the basketball court definitely not only
close I know comparison I played
basketball my whole life I've been able
to dribble since I could walk and you're
out there with teammates and it's just a
it's a natural thing to me this is
unlike anything else but that's what I
love about it you go do something that
you are a little bit scared of and then
you do it and you walk away and you
realize oh I can do that not necessarily
is like how comedians can bring it but
it kind of gives me a new tool and it
gives me something that you know kind of
shakes my comfort zone do you have like
do you have any like pregame for
basketball rituals that you do
superstitions really superstitions but I
definitely have like a routine that yes
do yeah do you have a routine for doing
stand-up it's so stand-up is so like you
know like I did a show last night and it
was like I get to the theater and I'm on
in 15 or whatever it is and I have a
little bit of time to go off on myself
but no it's it's it's so sporadic you
basketball it's such a controlled things
really especially the NBA
every game is the exact same right you
know what I mean you you have the same
same lead-up so no like I said there's
literally zero comparisons but you seem
so chill right now like won't even like
whatever half an hour before you do this
that you have any nerves about yeah I'll
go onstage I'll be you know will be
anxious for sure I think the key thing
you do that you care about you should be
a little anxious for you don't be a
little nervous for cell that doesn't
really bother me as much anymore yeah
right now I just watched the video with
you and Kevin Hart a couple days ago and
in the ice is it caught we surprised at
how long it took them to get into that
ice bath I was uh I was too I'm always
disappointed um no I think they kind of
like walked us through how it's gonna go
down and do do those ice-pops they do it
almost every day oh do you oh yeah so
but they also never get easier right
even if you do it every day it's not
like how you do it every day and I
reckon it's not cold it's always cold
I'm actually seeing Kevin tomorrow you
have like a message forever a question I
should ask Kevin tell him to ask him why
he didn't he didn't come here tonight so
this is so this basketball stuff the
comedy stuff like I mean you're really
becoming a celebrity now like is that
weird for you that it's gone beyond just
playing basketball like any people care
about your personal life people like the
tabloids is a weird there's a whole
other aspect to your fame now a little
bit just because I think as a kid you
want to play in the NBA you don't
realize you know what all is gonna
probably come along with it but at the
same time it's you know it's you can't
complain about being able to have a
reach and being able to influence people
that's why we do like the stuff that we
do because I've been blessed with the
ability to have a reach and have a have
a platform to be able to share you know
a message whatever it is and and you
know we've also been able to use that
for good so you can't just look at the
bad you gotta you gotta appreciate the
good as well right now bring you back
the Raptors we're all very sad that we
lost qilin 'red
to the Clippers your former team do you
have any like words of advice or
charisma for the Toronto people or
Canadians in general that we've lost
quite because we were obsessed with
choir we follow them around to places
exactly I mean listen you guys got you
guys have to suffer through this now I
mean listen I think that championship
and what it did for this country was
awesome but it was big for basketball as
well because you know there there might
be a kid that watched you know that
playoff run that championship run and
you know now he might think about
basketball a little bit differently and
think that I can do that you know
hopefully one day he'll change the into
basketball as well so what what happened
here was was huge not heinous over here
but in Canada was huge and and it was it
was excited if you're a basketball fan
you appreciate it yeah and classes is a
fun guy so maybe we can come up next
year for a comedy back Blake I need to
work on him a little bit creo
unbelievable